when garden gnomes go missing I'm sure
I'll help you find them
Romeo and Juliet will have to team up
with the sneaky freaky leekie the cheeky
to form the greatest team ever known
booth that was super cheesy you beat up
DeeDee
hubba-hubba Romeo and Juliet are moving
to a whole new garden all clear
it's not quite perfect but it's ours
think of all the adventures we're gonna
have me
oh man Katie that is just are you done
humans coming hoses everyone they were
supposed to live happily ever after but
when their world is in danger Julia
the gnomes the roeckl there's only one
known to call and Sherlock knows sworn
protector of garden gnomes
you mean except for the one you
literally just broke we can't let anyone
hear this but they're going to smashes
all already picture
we have to get across that River you
need a ship no [ __ ] Sherlock
you've got a great unknown hey our next
clue is in the park directions quickly
this follow the blue line on the ground
until you find the giant red Suns
MacAvoy Emily Blunt - attila tear poor
mary j blige and Johnny Depp with
original music by Elton John and Bernie
Taupin you have to go him to cover let's
go
- forward hold Oh forgive me I've never
been the back end of a spoiler before
a lot knows that's not how a squirrel
fix it's behind mankini can you
demonstrate use andouille you see yes
you're acting like a rear end
you